son unos 10 días de luto por la muerte
de la reina Cuáles serán los protocolos
Durante este tiempo
Bueno pues en primer lugar Buenas noches
gracias por la invitación Lo primero es
que
el primer lugar la primera
manifestación será el discurso de Carlos
muy muy esperado en el que muy
seguramente va a señalar un talante
acerca de lo que él Espera que va a ser
su reinado
hay un cierre de la bolsa de Londres que
es muy importante
durante tres días por lo menos hay
obviamente dentro de los próximos 10
días se debe llevar a cabo las las los
funerales de la Reina Isabel segunda y
como decía ahorita Tu colega
hay que esperar muy buen tiempo hasta
Incluso un año para la ceremonia de
investidura de Carlos III
ahora cómo afectan estos operativos la
cotidianidad de los británicos
a ver aquí hay dos eso tiene dos
dimensiones
en realidad hay una parte simbólica
obviamente hay unos días de duelo que se
van a sentir no solamente en el Reino
Unido sino muy seguramente los estados
de la common Wells y dentro de los
estados de la coma en Word mucho más
aquellos que reconocían a la reina como
jefe de estado aquí seguramente habrá
una sociedad
en shock especialmente la la sociedad
mayor digámoslo así las nuevas
generaciones tengo una presión que no es
tan tan conectadas
Y en segundo lugar no debería haber
mayores traumatismos por ejemplo en el
sentido económico hay que recordar a la
gente que la salida de la reina no
implica ninguna transición económica
ningún cambio por ejemplo en el régimen
de inversiones extranjera esto no
tendría por qué causar pánico en los
mercados por ejemplo como cuando cae un
gobierno en algún estado y hay
incertidumbre respecto a lo que pueda
suceder en el corto plazo entonces me
parece que hay un trauma que es más que
todo social
eh y muy seguramente Esto va a dejar un
impacto en el en el próximo reinado de
Carlos III
mencionaba que no hay grandes cambios a
nivel económico por ejemplo pero sí en
los símbolos británicos Qué cambios
podemos ver en este aspecto por ejemplo
bueno Pues básicamente vamos a ver un
desapego de la de la gente del común con
la monarquía una de las principales
cualidades que se le reconocía a la
Reina Isabel era el gran sentido del
carisma era una reina considerada muy
muy cerca de la gente que se tomaba
fotos
tenía ciertas apariciones mediáticas mi
impresión es que ese carisma no lo tiene
Carlos tercero en el último tiempo ha
habido una serie de escándalos que
incluso comprometen a su hermano Andrés
en un en un escándalo de abuso sexual su
pasado la manera como terminó casándose
con con Camila Parker y todo este pasado
con Diana de gales de alguna manera
empañan la figura Entonces yo creo que
aquí va a haber una un cambio importante
de la legitimidad de la monarquía yo
creo que va a ser difícil mantener ese
nivel de legitimidad
y internacionalmente algo que debe sobre
lo cual se debe llamar la atención y es
que muy seguramente
van a empezar a circular estos reclamos
reclamos acerca de la colonia por hechos
de Perdón por los cuales jamás la
monarquía pidió Perdón muy a pesar del
pedido de algunos estados esto como en
el caso de Palestina o de la India que
le pidieron la monarquía a pedir perdón
y esto nunca nunca sucedió entonces acá
lo que creo yo es que esta idea de la
monarquía como un símbolo de unidad
nacional va a quedar seriamente
debilitada
bien logrará Ahora el fallecimiento de
la Reina Isabel segunda por ejemplo unir
a los británicos que se ha mostrado
divididos en temas como el brexit la
guerra en Ucrania y la crisis que han
atravesado los últimos gobiernos
conservadores
Yo pienso que no Y acá es un poco lo que
recalcaba hay una sociedad polarizada
por el día a día y una vez superado el
shock que esto tendrá que pasar en las
próximas semanas los británicos se van a
tener que enfrentar uno a la crisis del
combustible del gas que está viviendo
Europa a propósito de la guerra en
Ucrania ahí digamos que eso ese tipo de
coyunturas tienden a polarizar más
frente a la posición del Reino Unido en
ese conflicto en segundo lugar la la
responsabilidad del partido conservador
del brexit es un tema que todavía causa
divisiones en buena medida Porque
todavía hay un sector de los británicos
que sienten que el partido conservador
de manera irresponsable los llevó a ese
escenario y además se pactó muy mal en
la época de Boris Johnson ese ese brexit
entonces yo pienso que obviamente en
estos días habrá una suerte de unidad
nacional por el shock que genera la
muerte de la de la reina Pero superar la
polarización como ocurre en el resto de
Europa va a ser muy difícil en la medida
en que se acerque el invierno y muy
seguramente la penuria la carencia de
gas Se va se va a sentir mucho más en
una economía que además viene alicaída
por la ausencia de mano de obra las
dificultades de Los Pescadores para
exportar su pescado al resto de de
Europa la caída de la de la bolsa luego
del brexit de Londres pasó de ser la
capital bursátil en Europa para ser
reemplazada por por amsterdam es decir
hay una serie de factores que que va a
ser muy difícil de superar por más de
que la muerte de la reina congrega los
británicos alrededor de su figura
y ahora Qué cambios políticos en materia
internacional conlleva la muerte de la
reina
muy pocos porque en realidad la política
exterior del Reino Unido está está en
manos del Primer Ministro lo que uno
podía ver por ejemplo Y esa era una de
las grandes equilibrios que conseguía la
monarquía si uno ve por ejemplo el
desprestigio de Tony Blair por por su
apoyo a la guerra en Irak el
desprestigio de David Cameron por el
brexito de Boris Johnson en fin de buena
parte de los primeros ministros la
figura de la reina muy digna manteniendo
la estabilidad la unidad nacional
compensaba un poco ese descrédito y ese
descrédito Me parece que en buena medida
ocurre por algunas de las decisiones en
política exterior como la guerra de
Hidalgo El brexit esto muestra que
básicamente la monarquía tiene muy poca
incidencia en la proyección yo la verdad
es que en términos de política exterior
Reino Unido va a perder prestigio porque
la monarquía va a perder prestigio Y
como decía hace un rato
yo creo que en algunos países del sur
global
como la India algunos países del Caribe
e incluso Como ya pasó a ser
relativamente poco con Palestina van a
volver Los reclamos los pedidos de
perdón a la monarquía y se va a revivir
la Espinosa cuestión colonial que muy
seguramente va a afectar la imagen del
Reino del mundo como ya le ha sucedido a
otros países como en el caso de Francia
con Argelia